el Ministerio de defensa de Ucrania
confirma que los combates siguen al
interior de la población de soledad en
el corazón del donbas una población
famosa por sus minas de sal que está en
el centro de la lucha por esta región en
los últimos días esto coincide con las
versiones dadas por algunos soldados que
están desplegados en la cercanías de
Soledad especialmente de la ciudad de
bacmut que hablan de que al menos del
30%
de tropas ucranianas sigue en la ciudad
donde se da una lucha calle por calle
Ellos hablan que si bien algunas
brigadas se habrían retrocedido por
orden militar los integrantes del menos
otras tres estarían luchando en el
interior y también en las vías aledañas
a soledad esta población está solamente
a siete kilómetros de debate que es
realmente el objetivo actual de las
fuerzas de Moscú y muchos incluso desde
Rusia se ha dicho que tomar soledad les
ayudaría a rodear por completo esta
población sin embargo analistas
militares en Ucrania y también en Europa
dicen que esto no significa que la
población de que lleva luchándose por
meses vaya a caer porque dicen que uno
de los hechos que ha pasado en Soledad
es que decenas y decenas de hombres
rusos no solamente han caído en esta
batalla sino también han quedado heridos
y que su fuerza para atacar otras
regiones del donbas disminuiría sin
embargo hay otras fuentes que temen de
que haya un avance mayor y un ataque
mayor de las fuerzas de Moscú en los
próximos días y semanas ellos necesitan
Mostrar alguna Victoria ahora que se
cumple un año de la invasión el 24 de
febrero del año pasado así que están
acelerando al máximo para poder mostrar
a su población que tienen algún avance O
al menos es lo que dicen aquí en Ucrania